bonsoir alexis david lisnard donc il
prend la tête de l'aef un petit
camouflet pour la république en marche
oui puisqu'il y avait face à lui
quelqu'un qui avait derrière lui la
république en marche qui venait du
centre et qui n'a pas gagné qui venaient
même de la mf d'ailleurs david lisnard
si les maires de cannes il est en
campagne depuis quelques mois il a
milité au national et il vient des
républicains et chose à souligner il a
commencé sa carrière en étant proche du
vice-président de cette association des
maires de france donc il connaît bien ce
système là il faut voir que derrière
évidemment il y avait la velléité des
modèles macron de prendre cette
association indépendante des maires de
france pour en faire un outil de
campagne éventuellement ou moins ancrée
cette politique de la république en
marche dans les territoires puisque il
lui a été longtemps critiquée le fait
d'être un président hors sol un
président qui n'est pas ancrée dans les
territoires pas proche des élus locaux
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que dès 2017
et mme nelles macron lui s'était
rapproché de l'association des chasseurs
un autre lobby assez puissant dans la
ruralité mais pour les mères c'est un
échec la preuve avec cette élection de
david lisnard aujourd'hui au delà alexis
des des ambitions personnelles
un poste on imagine de choix pour poser
dans la campagne
et oui un républicain à la tête de
l'association des maires de france c'est
la continuité d'une certaine façon mais
c'est aussi important puisque les maires
sont ceux qui donnent les parrainages
aux candidats à la présidentielle et
puis c'est aussi à un poste national qui
permet de donner de la voix surtout
quand on vient d'être élu et de pouvoir
peser pour un candidat ou un autre alors
je pense que david lisnard restera
discret dans la campagne pour le congrès
en tant que le candidat de la droite ne
sera pas choisie mais une fois fait il
aura un poste de choix pour bien sûr
pousser les idées des républicains et
donner une tribune même si bien sûr
l'association des maires de france
travaille pour tous les maires elle est
apolitique mais ça reste quand même une
position médiatique qui permet d'avoir
une visibilité que n'ont pas les autres
le maire français est clairement l'a71
un coup d'épée dans l'eau pourrait
manuel macron puisqu'elle lui n'a pas
réussi à placer quelqu'un proche de
cette maison commune 1 qu'il souhaite
bâtir pour supporter ça sa candidature
sa nouvelle candidature à sa réélection
alex emmanuel macron dont elle est maire
c'est une longue série de rendez vous
manqués peut-il encore rattraper les
choses parce qu'on a assisté quand même
aussi une petite séquence de
calinothérapie aujourd'hui ont
complètement alors emmanuel macron est
très conscient de ses limites et de ses
défauts il ne fait depuis le mois de
septembre que colmater sur le régalien
sur la sécurité sur l'éducation sur
plein de choses en fait il est en train
de colmater les brèches pour faire
campagne à droite toute donc là
évidemment ils voulaient colmater les
brèches et les malentendus comme il le
dit lui même avec les maires de france
on se souvient quand même que ça avait
été un sommet boudé à l'époque il
n'avait pas voulu venir les voir il y
avait tout à sico drame autour de ça et
puis clairement il ya un président qui
est vu comme
internationaliste monde un citadin coupe
et finalement de la ruralité ce que ne
sont pas les mères donc ils essayent la
de rattraper un peu les morceaux c'est
un peu tard évidemment il est en
campagne donc c'est normal il fait un
discours de campagne que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement verbeux extrêmement vide
aussi de dire qu'il faut une cohésion
que évidemment les maires sont le
premier ciment il a essayé de défendre
sa politique puisque les municipalités
ont perdu beaucoup d'argent avec les
réformes des miels macron alors il s'en
est défendu en disant que non tout ça
avait été compensée et qu'il était là
pour les aider et non pas pour que le
président soit contre les élus on voit
bien que la mésentente persiste qu'il ya
surtout une incompréhension finalement
de ces les attentes du pays est aussi
une vision très jacobine du pouvoir très
centralisé très verticale ou emmanuel
macron voudraient décider de tout avec
les préfère qu'il a nommé d'ailleurs à
la appel lorsqu'il était président il
l'est toujours d'ailleurs mais l'idée
est de dire je veux travailler avec vous
parce que la campagne commence et que
s'il a tous les maires de france
beaucoup de maires de france qui vont
être contre c'est sa politique ça va
être compliqué de faire campagne au
local parce que il ya très peu
d'adhérents la république en marche qui
peuvent faire campagne sur le terrain
alexis blanc d'avoir été avec nous